the washington post reports that china
is currently in the process of
modernizing and diversifying
its fleet of nuclear warheads the
defense department now expects that
china's arsenal will have quadrupled
within the next decade by 2030 the
communist nation should have more than a
thousand nuclear warheads among them
will be a certain number of hypersonic
orbital missiles which can circle the
globe without being detected and of
course that's not new technology and
china still will have fewer nuclear
nuclear weapons than we do i mean enough
to destroy the entire planet so probably
that's sufficient
but we'll still have more but the point
though is that they seem focused on
strengthening their position and
becoming a more formidable global force
while we have
well other priorities in an interview
with npr general david berger
announced that the marine corps will be
overhauling and reinventing itself in
order to institute more diversity not
nuclear diversity but the type of
diversity that politically correct hr
representatives are worried about
reading from yahoo news it says
according to burger marines will work to
quote reflect america to reflect the
society we come from adding that the
decision is not one related to being
woke or politically correct
sure whatever you say quote our
advantage militarily is on top of our
shoulders burger said it's not actually
our equipment we are better than anybody
else primarily because we don't all
think exactly alike we didn't come from
the same backgrounds
now far be it for me it's a question the
esteemed general um
i didn't serve in the military
i never fought in any war i admit that
even so i'm skeptical that any military
engagement has ever been won due to a
due to you know diversity of ethnic
backgrounds among the victors
can anybody point me to an example for
military history
of a battle that was won
because of diversity
i'm trying to imagine back say during
the normandy invasion a group of
soldiers pinned down taking heavy enemy
fire
one of them shouts we need someone with
a diverse ethnic background over here
stat
it's hard for me to picture that
you know i i can't see why that would
have specifically helped
but the marines are all in on their
diversity plan anyway in fact as fox
news reports they're paying big bucks to
make this happen quote uh from the
report a job listing with the u.s marine
corps seeking a diversity equity and
inclusion advisor with a starting salary
of 144 thousand dollars is gaining
attention on social media the usmc is
hiring the advisor to ensure that quote
all internal and external communications
reflect diversity equity and inclusion
or dei
and to develop tools that enable
shifting the usmc cultural paradigm for
diversity equity and inclusion
the dei advisor will work in
collaboration with the chief diversity
officer and the diversity review board
the listing states
duties include the assessment of
diversity and inclusion program
effectiveness design and lead implement
implementation of process improvement
initiatives
and provide executive level consultation
i don't know what any of that means as
well as the development and
administering of training and education
guidance to the cdo
it says quote you will drive strategic
management concepts and principles
including assisting with the development
of marine corps policy supporting the
usmc's mission vision values strategic
goals and objectives according to the
listing
now needless to say 144 000 a year is
significantly more
than any of the men
out actually doing the fighting are
getting paid
so risk your life for your country and
get paid about the same as i don't know
papa john's ship shift supervisor or
less
but sit behind a desk developing equity
and inclusion strategies
and you know that's where the big bucks
are made
at any rate if you want more information
on our military's diversity plans you'll
be happy to know that you can go to the
marine corps association website and
download their full
diversity equity and inclusion plan as
written by lieutenant general david
otignon and brigadier general jason
woodworth here you'll find details about
what this chief diversity officer will
do
and you can learn about the formation of
the aforementioned diversity review
board which the marines will be using as
they strive to achieve their diversity
goals and this is not just about racial
diversity of course as they explain
quote today's marine corps is 58 white
and 42 minority from 2010 to 2020
enlisted diversity grew from 33 percent
to over 45 percent and our officer
diversity grew from 16 to 34
female diversity continues to climb each
year and is currently over 9
these are signs that we are making
positive progress but much but much work
remains to be done to retain and promote
a more diverse equitable and inclusive
force across all ranks
now again we must ask the question from
before
in the whole history of military
conflict
across the entire globe
has there ever been a battle won because
one side was more inclusive and
equitable than the other
i i don't think so
in fact battles have been won with the
exact opposite approach
rather than diversity
militaries have always valued
cohesiveness
uniformity
that's why units march in formation
that's why we call them units
it's why they literally wear things
called uniforms
individuality has never been emphasized
instead it's been subordinated
ruthlessly sometimes to the needs of the
unit the group the whole as for
inclusiveness and equity our military
was a formidable fighting force a
two-time world champion
because it set standards for itself that
excluded those who were unfit
those who couldn't hack it
the military has never been a democracy
it's never been a place for individual
expression
it has never been a beacon of tolerance
or equality the military is a hierarchy
all militaries are hierarchies
there is no equality or equity in a
hierarchy there can't be
there's never been a democratic military
there's never been a tolerant military
there's never been anything like what
they are currently turning it into right
now so once again we see that the left
project
is to demolish deconstruct and
fundamentally rebuild and redefine
everything every american institution
every organization every tradition
every word every idea
terms like politically correct and woke
don't really even begin to capture
what's actually happening in our country
and what these people intend to do to it
one other point worth
reiterating it's important when we
engage with these ideas like diversity
and inclusion that we don't make the
mistake of accepting the premise that
the left actually wants diversity and
inclusion
i mean that would be bad enough if that
is what they wanted diversity and
inclusion are terrible goals in and of
themselves
especially for a military
but really for any institution
diversity and inclusion should never be
the priority and if they were the real
priorities here there there would be
plenty to criticize about that but we
should also keep in mind that all of
these words diversity inclusion equity
tolerance etc they are all code for
get rid of white males
i mean that's that's really what this is
about
after all when they talk about
increasing the percentages of some
demographics
you know demographics that are not white
and male what that means is reducing the
percentage of white males just basic
math there
the goal of the military right now is
not just to get more black people and
women involved
because if the participation rates of
blacks and women grew and the
participation of white males grew at the
same time and at the same rate
you wouldn't see an increase in the
former group in terms of percentage
but they're talking about percentage
which means that the military very
specifically wants to drive white males
out
so they they frame it in a positive way
oh we want a greater percentage of this
group
but they could just as easily say we
want fewer of this group
we want fewer of those types
and you know the very group that's done
most of the fighting and dying for this
country the military wants them gone
thank you for your service now get out
this point is often made pretty explicit
when the topic of diversity comes up
take for instance this conversation on
msnbc over the weekend about now this
isn't diversity in the military this is
diversity in the trucking industry and
they've made it very clear what it's uh
what they're really concerned about
listen
you hear i have to tell you my brother
is a truck driver um and he drives
across the country and it's very
nerve-wracking to me uh when he's on the
road
um
because it's just it feels like a
dangerous industry but you're trying to
disrupt that and bring more people who
look like us to the industry tell us why
yes ma'am first of all thank you for
having me this morning and yes we are
and we say we're not building truck
drivers but safe cmb operators folks
that can get back to their home whenever
they're done with their ship that's the
most important part man
well how can the industry be more
welcoming because i have to tell you i
talked to a lot of truck drivers and uh
preparing for this segment and um most
of these truck drivers were people of
color and they talked about um you know
hearing some of the racism um over the
cb um you know this is again an industry
populated um by a lot of white men over
the age of 55. um this group of people
overwhelmingly voted for trump um some
people have talked about you know
aggressive truck drivers cutting them
off or not being helpful um so obviously
the more populated it is with people of
color i think you'll see less of that
but how can you encourage people to come
and disrupt this space when it seems a
bit unwelcoming
well i think just what you're doing
getting uh myself as a black female out
there and letting people know i drove
for almost eight years and yes ran into
lots of racism but however was out there
to do my job and i think that uh women
are definitely the more we can just get
the news out to them that trucking is an
industry that will not only help them to
get further in life but their family and
all that and present the package to them
appropriately regardless of what anybody
else has to say they're going to be in
charge they're going to be the person
behind that steering wheel doing the job
every single day and making it happen
just out and out racism
i mean we're used to it by now
you picked up of course where she said
uh there's a lot of white males over 55
and people complain about um they're
sometimes aggressive and rude and so
obviously if we have more people of
color as truck drivers there will be
less of that kind of behavior
right oh yeah well obviously white
people are more rude and aggressive she
says really do you have any
data on that
let me see the statistics on that
but yes this is why women haven't
flocked to the trucking industry
every day i meet another woman whose
deepest desire is to be a long-haul
trucker driving a big rig across the
country spending her nights sleeping in
the cab in the back of a walmart parking
lot showering in gas stations
now this is what they most fervently
want but they aren't doing it because
the trucking industry is sexist
i mean
like i said every day i meet another
woman with that story don't you
what i really wanted to be was a
long-haul trucker they all say
my wife too she tells me all the time
what she always wanted as a young girl
was to you know get to get in that truck
drive across the desert
now the msnbc anchor speaks with disdain
about those uh white males over 55 who
drive trucks the ones who make sure that
she has food to eat and clothes to wear
i mean her lifestyle depends on those
men but she hates them
rather than saying thank you
which is what you should be that's what
you're missing here
you see a lot of people on the left
never had had never had parents to tell
them what do you say you say thank you i
say with my kids all the time you know i
hand them a snack
what do you say thank you
well to this msnbc anchor what do you
say you say thank you to the white males
who are making your life easier we're
allowing you to live by providing all of
these things to you
but rather than saying thank you uh she
wants them she wants them gone she wants
them jobless and homeless that's how she
feels
that's what all this diversity and
inclusion stuff is really about it's an
anti-white male conspiracy first and
foremost
and in the process it strips people of
their humanity and it reduces them to
statistics
a white person driving a truck is not a
person according to msnbc he is a
faceless representative for his race
which is running a surplus
you know the white person supply exceeds
the white person demand at least
according to the corporate media
there must be a white person clearance
sale so that we can clean our shelves
and restock them with more valuable
racial merchandise
this is essentially how our social
engineers view the problem
which is only a problem in the first
place because they've decided to call it
one
you know the problem of there being a
lot of white males over 55 driving
trucks
there's no it's not a problem at all
but they've decided that it's a problem
but if we're really worried about
fighting racism and inequality
then the goal should be a society where
a person
can live where they want
work where they want if they're
qualified pursue whatever opportunity
they want
go to school where they want
again if they qualify on the merits to
go to school
without anyone caring about their skin
color or their ethnic background
you know in this scenario a man would be
judged on his merits alone and he would
climb as far in life as those merits
will take him
but that's not how our society operates
because that's not what the proponents
of forced diversity want
they want division resentment and racism
and that's what they've gotten
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated